was ist nicht schon alles über diese
sehr langen tische in moskau gesagt
worden an dem sie alle platz nehmen muss
im makro
us-präsident beiden wenn auch nur
virtuell
und zuletzt olaf scholz der tisch als
symbol mehr entfremdung zwischen ost und
west geht nicht
dabei hatte alles einmal ganz anders
angefangen ein jahr nach amtsantritt
besucht putin 2001 deutschland und hält
eine rede im bundestag auf deutsch das
spricht er fließend nach seiner zeit als
kgb agenten dresden heute müssen wir
auch fest und endgültig erklären der
kalte krieg ist vorbei
die welt befindet sich auf einer
die welt befindet sich auf einer neuen
etappe ihrer entwickeln wir verstehen
ohne einer modernen dauerhaften und
standfester internationalen
sicherheitsarchitektur schaffen wir auf
dem kontinent nie vertrauens klima an
und ohne diesen vertrauens klima ist
kein einheitliches großer vermögen heute
sind wir verpflichtet zu sagen dass wir
unseren unsere stereotypen und
ambitionen loswerden und der bevölkerung
europas und der ganzen welt sicherheit
zusammen gewährleisten
russland will mitspielen putin will
ernst genommen werden doch seine
erwartungen erfüllen sich nicht
russischer perspektive ist die
freundlichkeit nicht freundlich
beantwortet worden sondern die pläne die
russland hatte sind gewissermaßen kalt
abgeprallt westen war nicht bereit
darüber zu reden die nato sollte die
zentrale institutionen der europäischen
sicherheits ordnung sein die nato hat
sich erweitert russland wollte das von
anfang an nicht sondern wollte
gleichberechtigt in diesen fragen
mitreden und die nato hat gewissermaßen
russland einen platz am katzentisch
zugewiesen das hat russland nie gefallen
putin wird sich später mit einem hund
revanchieren labrador koni ist 2007
dabei als angela merkel kommt dabei
weist ihn ganz genau dass die
bundeskanzlerin angst vor hunden hat
fast trotzig wirkt der russische
präsident bei seinem letzten g8-gipfel
in nordirland so sieht einer aus der
weiß dass er nicht dazu gehört
ein jahr später wird er nicht mehr dabei
sein die treffen finden ohne russland
ohne putin statt
da hat russland gerade die krim besetzt
völkerrechtswidrig und führt krieg in
der ost ukraine
seit acht jahren wird in der region
gekämpft gibt es tote müssen menschen
ihre häuser ihre heimat verlassen
rascher hast du changes russland muss
seinen weg ändern ich meine wir
konzentrieren uns sehr darauf was
russland von uns fordert und ich bin der
ansicht dass wir uns auch darauf
konzentrieren sollten was wir von
russland fordern von russland besetzt
direktorium das ukraine gehört es hat
eine rebellion in der ukraine
angezettelt
es ist ein bedrohungsszenario dass
russland langsam erweitert
militärmanöver 2017 in belarus dh direkt
vor der haustür von polen litauen
lettland und estland alles nato
mitglieder
die nato verlagert im gegenzug
kampftruppen ins baltikum das misstrauen
wächst bewaffnete nato jets werden zur
luftraumüberwachung eingesetzt
allein im vergangenen jahr fangen sie
290 russische flugzeuge haben
es ist so etwas wie ein vorspiel für den
aktuellen konflikt wieder lässt putin
panzer aufziehen zu manövern in belarus
und an der grenze zur ukraine bis zu 150
tausend russische soldaten und auf
einmal ist sie wieder da die angst vor
einem krieg in europa sie haben uns in
den 90er jahren gesagt aber kein
zentimeter richtung osten und was ist
passiert wir wurden betrogen wir wurden
dreist betroffen
was putin also wirklich versucht zu
erreichen ist in einem gewissen umfang
die derzeit in europa bestehende
sicherheitsorganen herauszufordern
worden einer nato erweiterung ein ende
zu bereiten und sicherzustellen dass die
ukraine die meist mitglied der nato wird
und wenn möglich die militärische
präsenz westlicher länder in der nähe
der russischen grenze zu reduzieren
strategisch eiskalt einen den der westen
ernst nehmen muss dass es die botschaft
die putin seinen internationalen gästen
mit gibt ein taktierer dessen plan am
ende aufgehen könnte
dazu ist er offenbar auch bereit erster
einheiten von der ukrainischen grenze
abzuziehen
es geht um vitale interessen russlands
und länder sind das zeigt die geschichte
für vitale interessen bereit auch krieg
zu führen und in diesem fall ist das
auch so ich glaube russland ist
entschlossen das jetzt den versuch zu
machen das durchzusetzen was er sich
vorgenommen hat und wenn es dazu militär
braucht dann wird es vermutlich dazu
kommen wenn es ohne geht glaube ich es
ist auch ein russischer perspektive die
deutlich bessere option
putin der starke mann im kreml einer der
dem westen seinen willen auf drückt wenn
nicht mehr als freund auf augenhöhe dann
als ernstzunehmender gegner
[Musik]